arnold schwarzenegger is the youngest
ever mr olympia winner in history
and an iconic actor best known for his
portrayal of the terminator he went from
growing up poor in
austria spending time in military prison
for going awol
during training in order to compete in a
bodybuilding contest
to becoming the most important figure in
bodybuilding history
the world's most popular actor and a
governor of california
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe
nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best arnold schwarzenegger and my take
on his top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one just do it
people should just realize
that i'm not gonna have any sympathy
for any of those things you know when
someone says it's difficult because
there is
a lot of things in life that are
difficult
and you have to ask yourself the
question right off the top
you know are you going to be one of
those guys that are going to go and back
off every time something is difficult or
do you want to be one of those guys that
says look it doesn't matter if
it's easy or difficult almost
difficult i'm going to go and crush
through it
that's me that's the person that i want
to be
and i'm going to prove it to myself and
i'm going to prove it to the rest of the
world
so yeah there are certain things that
are difficult this is difficult for
people to
have a routine but they just have to go
and do that
and they should just work on it where
they go and say do something very simple
i'm gonna go and get up every morning at
let's say an hour early
before they normally get up and just
work on that
and then the next time they work on it
and say okay i'm gonna get up early and
i'm gonna go and make my coffee or my
tea or whatever
and i'm gonna read papers even though
maybe i haven't read the paper yet
in the last 10 years just add that to
you
and don't even ask about it shooter or
should i not that's the key thing about
the routine is
that you don't ask yourself should i or
shouldn't i
you just do it rule number two develop
your mind
and body in order to be complete
and that's when you really have a 100
chance at being successful when you have
a complete situation that means that you
have developed
your body meaning your health your
strength
your energy and all that makes you much
more positive
right because that's when you wake up
when you feel strong and you feel fit
then you write the basically in the
morning
you know the whole world looks much more
bright so the the the training of the
body
extremely important the training of the
mind
extremely important this is why i say to
people i say you got to educate yourself
you got to read something every day you
got to learn a new language
you got to just always improve and look
at what can you do to improve your
business or your life in general
so to develop the mind and then to
develop the spiritual side and the soul
extremely important also so if we put
those three things together
we have total completion and this is why
the physical training
and i'm not talking about wanting to win
mr olympia no
we're talking about just take some light
weights
and do your reps pump up the body you
know and get some blood in there
then go and run go and run the stairs go
and exercise
go to a yoga class and do some weight
training
or when you have kids go out and play
sports you know just
you know go football playing and go
soccer playing and tennis playing and
this
whatever you can that is what creates
kind of life in you and therefore more
enthusiasm
and you have a much more positive
outlook in life rule number three
work hard
they say there's this magic pill that
will make you bacon stronger hercules
which one is the most perfectly
developed man in the world
they said we will make you a famous
actor and get you elected into public
office
it will give you superhuman strength in
the life of happiness
[Music]
and muscles
we say there is no magic pill
rule number four train the bottom line
is that you can train any time
of the day we learned it very quickly
and so i
kind of continued on with the tradition
i did two hours of working out in the
morning
and then two hours in the evening and
that routine
was automatic i didn't even think about
it my entire time in my bodybuilding
career
i always trained twice a day and never
ever
did i ask myself the question should i
go today and do the evening training
or should i get up in the morning i
always got up at five
six o'clock always and at seven o'clock
i worked out
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and self-love check out my
254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below
i was excited about uh taking a shot
the fact that it was so strange be you
be yourself whether it's in
entertainment whether it's
out in public whether you're a celebrity
or not
whatever the most powerful thing you can
be is yourself
playing these characters and doing this
it's been a great combination like a
really good year to just push the
envelope
and i think that's always what i want to
do rule number five believe
the bigger your goals are and the more
outrageous they are
or especially if someone else has never
done it yeah
then the people will always say this is
crazy this will never happen
you cannot do that that's impossible and
all those things and so you know we have
heard all the naysayers and everything
like that
and uh you just cannot pay any attention
to that because it's just the way it is
and so i'm
i always feel like if i can see it
and if i can believe it then i can
achieve it rule number six
have routines i have a routine
which basically means they do something
we don't have to think much if at all
like uh i believe that routines are very
important
it's kind of like the foundation
like to a house or the building or do
anything
so that means like if i get up in the
morning
part of my routine is to get up in the
morning let's say five o'clock
then i make my coffee i feed the animals
i go and read the paper go through my
ipad
see if there are important messages so
that's part of the routine i don't even
think about that
i also part of the routine is that i
have my bike already mounted on the back
of my
car i drive down and then take it off
and i drive a ride with the bike to the
gym
in the morning around six so
then i go to the gym and they work at 45
minutes to an hour so that's always a
routine
it's always kind of the same thing and
that they do arms and deltoids one day
and the next day the chest
back and you know calves and all the
stuff i do every day and form a little
bit and
and abs of course every day uh and then
it repeats itself
and i do this the whole week and then
that what is also routine is that at
night
i do some extra cardiovascular work
before i have dinner
so i go for in my home gym here i go
upstairs and
go for half an hour and do the arm cycle
and or the treadmill or uh the
the the life cycle or something like
that that is cardiovascular
and the idea is to burn enough calories
so that when i eat dinner then which is
very minimal
you know that is i don't have to really
worry about calories or gaining weight
because the older you get
the faster you gain weight and the more
the body picks up because your
metabolism is slow so you have to be
very careful with that
so those are kind of routine things that
they do
and you try to add as many of those
routine things
as possible because you do then them
without ever thinking about it and
that's what we need to do there are
certain things that we need to do
that is supposed to be a routine that's
supposed to be kind of part of your
daily schedule
without you having to think about it and
uh so that's basically my
my kind of routine and i'm a big
believer in that rule number seven
have a bucket list i think you know
everyone
um has uh their own list of things
a bucket list of things that they always
wanted to do
i mean for me i always say say to myself
i think it would be great if i would
have enough time one time to just sit
here
and watch all the documentaries that i
always wanted to watch
you know i watch documentaries and i
watch movies
and i watch the news and all of this
stuff but you always feel like
there's just so much out there so much
content out there
that you would like to kind of see and
uh so
but everyone has different needs some
people feel like oh my
my wish list always was to spend more
time with my family
so then that's what you should do you
know play with you
if you're old like my age you play with
your grandkids maybe or with your kids
or uh you know and and have a good time
that way
um and hang out with your parents if you
still have parents
and all this stuff so everyone has a
different kind of a wish list of things
that they wish they could do
rule number eight concentrate i think
the biggest mistake is
that you go to the gym and you go
through the motion
but you don't really have your mind
inside the muscle
so when you do a bicep curl i can't just
stand there like this
yeah you can i've seen the guys training
with me
also four hours a day five hours a day
but they look like and why did they look
like
this because they didn't concentrate
they did the same exercise but they went
they stood they listened and they looked
sideways
kind of like they were bored because
they didn't even know why they were
training
that they wanted inside that bicep or
inside that lat when you do the rowing
and you pull
back and you flex the the upper back and
the center back and then you let it down
and you stretch it you think about that
the wing is coming out now
or like a curtain is opening up you know
we always thought about the curtain
right
this is when we did a loud spread so you
got to think about those things
when you do calf raises and i do my
donkey calf raises
i got to be inside the calves and to
make them
split to make them open up when those
guys sit on top of it you know first
three guys
then i have one guy jump off and it with
two guys then have another guy jump over
there there's one guy left
and on my back sitting and doing donkey
races you know some people looked at
this and this guy's doing some kinky
singing but anyway there was
something else this was as strange as
they didn't know what we were doing but
i tell you you got to be inside the
muscle the same is
when you do chest i mean when i when i'm
finished with a bench press
immediately i step in front of the the
mirror
and the flex i hit the shot and to see
everything how it works right and the
same as with the cable crosses when you
do afterwards cable crosses
i want to always see what happens rule
number nine
encourage others the bottom line is and
why i like to do
those seminars or those
lectures or those motivational speeches
or whatever you may call it
is because you can pump up people and
you can really give them this extra push
that they need
give them encouragement uh
give them kind of get them into a
positive thinking mode and all of those
things
because i know that i'm a product of
exactly that
i remember that when i was 15 years old
and picking up this magazine and reading
about rage park
i was so pumped up i went home
and all the things that i hated at home
and all of the things that i hated in
school all of a sudden disappeared
because now i had a purpose now i knew
where i was going
i read it in the magazine i said this is
what reg park did oh yeah he came from a
poor place
leeds it was a factory town it was dirty
and
polluted and everything like this that's
where he grew up that's kind of the way
i grew up here
and you know i followed his footsteps
and it worked and so this is why it is
so
if when he just just through a magazine
has this kind of a power over me imagine
now
if we go there and tell people
life you can do it you can do it
you can be the greatest do it go for it
get to the choppa you know whatever i
mean it's like you pump people up and
say this is why i like doing it because
uh i feel like i'm a product of a lot of
encouragement from so many people
so i want to do the same because
remember in the end
we i always say we're not judged by how
much we make but we're judged by how
much we give
back how much do we give so that's what
i want to give something back
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have fun basically i'm gonna play
howard
a physical fitness instructor who has
become a regional manager
for gold's gym i'm howard kleiner
i'm here to help you and we're doing all
of this crazy stuff
to raise some money for something kind
of serious which is after school
programs
see you tomorrow i'll see you tomorrow
all right keep that up hello how are you
how are you good thank you all right can
i help you
i forgot my key card what does a keycard
mean
you look like you're sweating a little
bit let me just take care of everything
you have a towel
how's it going pretty good thanks
drinking a lot of water
that's good because remember 75 of the
body is water
keep drinking okay we're not finished
yet with the water drinking
when it burns it grows remember that
me maybe you saw me on the fbi most
wanted liz
you look very pumped up remember we do
everything in reps
so you've done two reps of water
drinking usually we do 10 reps of
everything so do another wrap of water
drinking
go down a little further you have elbows
and you have knees so touch them very
nice
stand up straight very good rep number
seven
you stop being a baby this is gorgeous
gym there's not a baby gym
and 10. very good you did it give me
five
that one ow why you hit so hard i see
some big guns back there hey look at
this come on now let's
see the guns you just remember paul
really poor
i love what i see and i see what i love
don't laugh
this is a serious business with the food
supplements
the psychology the mind the body what's
the most important thing
the weight training that's right baby
yeah how is my name there you have it
that's the face that i like
wow he looks so good
so handsome now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan and when you share your plan
and have public accountability
it raises your chances of following
through even higher
so that's what i want to do today for
you guys you watch this video
what was your single biggest takeaway
and what is your plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down in the comments below
because i was so enthusiastic about you
know
achieving my vision and turning my
vision into reality
and uh winning one championship after
the next there was always excitement and
enthusiasm there so when i went into the
gym
i put my gym bag down and i immediately
attacked the weights
there was no i mean many times we
started out by doing maybe
uh three four five minutes of ab work in
the beginning to warm up you know to do
maybe uh 500
uh roman chair sit ups or something like
that to warm up
and then we got right into it or we go
right into the whole thing but i mean it
was
right away warm up set then the next
weight up next wait up boom boom all the
way to the top until you just can't do
it
and super setting everything was always
super setting super setting super
setting
and uh three pump sets and four sets in
a row five steps in a row
so it really changed them what exercise
we did but it was always
all out and like i said the training
partner was always responsible
to challenge you at all times so that
was the thing i challenged my training
partners if it was frank zane if it was
dave draper
he was search your liver whoever with
the training partner was in any given
moment
we challenged each other kind of in a
fun way but i mean there was challenge
just so that
you don't slack off so you don't give
yourself a break
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated
brand new channel just for them if you
want to check it out go subscribe the
link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there